el que hereda
un gran éxito el que tiene unos padres
con una trayectoria profesional
extraordinaria
nace en una vara muy alta con un
estándar que espera de sí mismo y que
todos esperan de él
mucho más allá que de otra persona común
o normal porque es lo único que conoces
porque es tu realidad porque el ser
exitoso en cierto sentido es solamente
parte de tu vida es lo que ves es lo que
crees
es lo que éste identifica en cierta
manera
pero
todas las bendiciones todos los
privilegios
traen consigo una gran responsabilidad y
eso es en cierto modo lo que a mí me
preocupa que a veces no vemos y tal vez
por eso muchas de las personas que se
encuentran con la fama adultos jóvenes y
con el éxito
están perdidos porque se olvidan que una
gran bendición trae una gran
responsabilidad que el que más tiene es
el que más tiene que dar
que el ser exitoso conlleva obligaciones
conlleva requerimientos sacrificios
muchos sacrificios
pero que es el éxito
cuando busque la definición en en el
diccionario decía resultado en especial
feliz de una empresa o acción emprendida
de emprendimiento o un sucesos
feliz
resaltó la palabra feliz resaltó la
palabra acción son las acciones que
tomamos todos los días que nos hacen
sentir felices las que al final será
nuestro éxito el éxito es una palabra
compleja porque no hay una definición
única y lo que para mí es el éxito para
el otro no el éxito no tiene una fórmula
el éxito es personal es relativo es
subjetivo
está basado en valores está basado en lo
que cada quien identifique que le da
satisfacción
están los éxitos tangibles que son los
que todos conocen y los que muchos
entienden que son el parámetro para
lograr algo maravilloso el económico la
fama cuánto likes me dan en un instagram
y están aquellos intangibles que para mí
personalmente son los importantes
aquellos que nos dan un propósito de
vida aquellos que nos dan un sentimiento
extraordinario aquellos que nos permiten
todos los días amanecer y pensar
qué bien estoy contenta que logro
pero el éxito mío no es el éxito de esa
familia feliz no es el éxito que se ve
en las fotos mi éxito y mis fracasos han
sido mío y los he ido construyendo mi
vida y mi éxito ha sido que cada cosa
que hago lo hago con amor lo hago con
pasión he logrado hasta en los fracasos
sentir el éxito porque he tenido
fracasos y he salido airosa yo me he
casado dos veces en una familia donde la
familia per se es lo más importante
donde hasta nuestra empresa se conoce
como una gran familia
y para mí eso fue un gran fracaso
pero de este fracaso logré lo que muchos
tal vez no logran logré que mi
satisfacción más grande fue cuando mis
hijos me dijeron un día o le dijeron un
amigo que su papá y su mamá eran mejores
amigos
por lo tanto logré hacer de una relación
frágil y ya perdida en cierto sentido un
éxito
y continua mi vida siendo un éxito y hoy
día estoy casada con una persona a quien
amo sobre todas las cosas super super
feliz y hemos formado una familia nueva
entonces
mi éxito se basa en varias cosas para mí
mi éxito que todos tenemos cuatro formas
aspectos del éxito el personal el
profesional el físico y el emocional y
cada quien le da un valor diferente a
cada uno mi éxito profesional no es la
maravillosa empresa que tengo que es mi
responsabilidad pero mi área financiera
en mi éxito profesional es lograr los
objetivos que se necesitan para apoyar
lo que para mí es el éxito de mi empresa
que es que apoya a transformar vidas que
apoya a generar la diferencia en la zona
este del país que apoya a lograr que una
comunidad una región se desarrolle que
apoya a dejar huellas
y en eso baso mi éxito en dejar huellas
de la manera profesional trato de que
mis hijos puedan vivir el sueño que mis
padres iniciaron que yo continúo y que
quiero que sea el legado de ellos
asegurando así que la cultura de esta
empresa que amamos continúe soy mujer
soy líder soy líder de una gran empresa
pero mi mayor inversión en el futuro es
la educación de valores y académica de
mis hijos
y eso no se me puede olvidar porque
ellos son el futuro ellos son lo que
harán la diferencia si es muy difícil
ser madre ser esposa ser ex esposa
hija del líder profesional de una
empresa importante hay que dar un 350%
hay que pensar en cómo rendir el tiempo
hay que organizarse hay que enfocarse
pero todo lo que se hace con amor todo
lo que se hace con convicción se logra
yo todo lo que hago mi día es muy muy
muy muy ajetreado pero todo lo que hago
lo hago con amor todo lo que hago lo
hago tratando de marcar mi huella y
hacer una diferencia todo lo que hago le
entregó un 100% de mí
después no me pregunto si lo hice bien
lo hice mal miro para atrás sí pero
tampoco me voy a dar tres golpes porque
hice esto como lo debe haber sido
hago lo mejor que puedo y después confío
en dios
él tiene un poder mayor
trato todo el tiempo de hacer las cosas
como me enseñaron pero sobre todo
todo el tiempo trato de ser yo de no
perder mi esencia de no perder quien yo
soy ni perderme en el camino es muy
fácil perderse en el camino es muy fácil
olvidarse que es lo importante para ti
es muy fácil querer cumplir con los
sueños de todo el mundo menos de uno
pero no podemos olvidar que el sueño del
otro que la realidad en la que vives
tienes que cumplir tus sueños dentro de
esa realidad no podemos olvidar
quién es quién eres yo soy francesca
reinier y yo soy parte de esta identidad
que amo que respeto de cual me siento
orgullosa que trae consigo muchísimas
responsabilidades pero que trae consigo
tantos privilegios tantos orgullos
tantos sentimientos que orgullosa yo me
siento de pertenecer a esto que
orgullosa yo me siento de ser parte de
esa realidad
busquen su realidad construyan su propio
éxito recuerden que el éxito
es relativo a cada quien está en el adn
de cada quien y solamente es el
resultado del trabajo fuerte enfocado y
querido de cada quien tu éxito solamente
lo construyes tú
[Aplausos]